Republicans have yet again failed to
elect a speaker of the house despite
being poised to take control and swear
in their new elected members like George
Santos who has not actually been sworn
in yet even though he said he was we'll
get to that later despite the
endorsement of the failed former
president Donald Trump Kevin McCarthy
has lost again
and again
and yes again that makes it six total
times and this exposes number one the
complete inability to actually lead and
get things done productively even in the
easiest of circumstances like we have
control let's pick a speaker
it exposes increasingly the potentially
dwindling power and Prestige to the
extent extent that there was ever
Prestige of the Maga portion of the
Republican Party
and it also raises real national
security questions when you don't have a
speaker there are National Security
risks we will talk about that later as
well Rolling Stone reporting McCarthy
loses again despite nod from Trump the
House of Representatives has rejected
the California representative for a
fourth and probably not final time on
Wednesday subsequently rejecting him a
fifth time and then a sixth time and
then the voting set to pick back up
again today I'm sure by the time you
listen to today's program we may know
more there may have been more votes now
the despite the nod from Trump is very
interesting today's Thursday yesterday
was Wednesday on Tuesday when the first
votes for McCarthy failed
people uh NBC News went to Trump and
said do you still support McCarthy and
he didn't respond much later on in the
day Trump spoke to people presumably
checked out what Tucker Carlson was
saying Sean Hannity and others and then
he issued on Wednesday morning the
following
not reluctant but not exactly the most
ringing endorsement of Kevin McCarthy
saying on a truth social truth essential
quote some really good conversations
took place last night and now and it's
now time for all of our great Republican
house members to vote for Kevin close
the deal take the Victory and watch
crazy Nancy Pelosi fly back home to a
very broken California the only speaker
in U.S history to have lost the house
twice Republicans do not turn a great
Triumph into a giant embarrassing defeat
it's time to celebrate you deserve it
Kevin McCarthy will do a good job maybe
even a great job just watch not exactly
a full-throated endorsement and it
appears not to have quite been enough
not to be quite enough to get Kevin
McCarthy over the finish line now I
wrongly assumed yesterday
that it would become less and less
entertaining each time that Kevin
McCarthy lost each time that Kevin
McCarthy failed it has actually become
more entertaining each time because he
seems increasingly exasperated and
desperate now at this point there are
discussions of should Democrats make a
deal with Republicans to vote present
rather than to vote for Hakeem Jeffries
who Democrats have been completely
United behind the idea being or to
abstain from voting altogether and the
idea here is Democrats aren't going to
vote for a republican for house speaker
but would Democrats help lower the
threshold from the 218 needed votes
lower
so that maybe 212 gets Kevin McCarthy
the numbers that he needs I don't
believe democrats should do this the
idea that now it is Democrats who have
to come to the rescue of Republicans
because somewhere between 10 and 20
magats in the house are holding the
speakership hostage it is not for
Democrats to fix that now I recognize
there are National Security risks to not
having a speaker but that's on
Republicans and I hope that Democrats
don't do that the Counterpoint would be
are there six Republicans who can be
bought and who would vote for Hakeem
Jeffries now I don't mean a bribe I
don't mean literally take cash but what
I mean is are there six reasonable
Republicans in the house who are willing
to come to the table with Democrats and
say listen
you guys have a mess on your hands it's
a bigger mess than you know whatever
Trump is Flushing 10 to 15 times or
whatever analogy you want to use you
guys have a mess on your hands we are
united and we are ready to govern and we
could have debt ceiling issues that come
up we could have a natural disaster that
happens which we need to respond to
we've not sworn anyone in we don't have
a speaker this is a problem
be part of the solution we will be
willing to you know bring forward for
debate issues of importance to your
whatever a negotiation like adults are
there six Republicans willing to do that
I think the answer is no but it's worth
exploring that uh if you are the
Democrats before you're going to
acquiesce to these absurd demands from
people like Matt Gates and others it's
completely and totally pathetic so
that's what's going on six losses now
for Kevin McCarthy by the way the record
number of ballots
I believe it's 133 and it was a very
long time ago so we're nowhere close to
the record but certainly for the last
hundred years this is uh this is a
record so that's where we are right now
let's now talk about the explosively
growing Civil War within the the
Republican party and the right wing uh
about what's going on I'm going to show
you some stunning video here
propagandist Sean Hannity and radical
repugnant reactionary Republican
congresswoman Lauren bobert got into it
last night on Fox News Sean Hannity
increasingly seems sick of this
contingent of Maga that is
um holding up what could be Republicans
picking a speaker and getting everybody
sworn in and moving forward this is
really good this is the self-destructive
nature
of this party that is unable to govern
that doesn't care about policy that is
obsessed with cultural issues and going
anti-woke and all of this nonsense this
came to a head last night when Lauren
bobert appeared with Sean Hannity and
Hannity went right after her and I have
to say Hannity makes some statistically
good points here and I'll explain in a
moment take a look at this you said
complimentary things about President
Trump needs to tell Kevin McCarthy that
sir you do not sir it's time to a draw
let me turn the tables congresswoman
Kevin McCarthy is 202-3 votes your site
has 20. so if I'm going to use your
words and your methodology and your math
uh isn't it time for you to pack it in
in your side to pack it in considering
he has over 200 and you have 20. now
this is strictly speaking true Hannity
is completely correct if you want to
talk about who's being stubborn or
obstinate or holding this up despite not
having the numbers on their hands it is
a sort of tyranny of this minority of
the Republican Party most of the
Republican party is United but the rules
are the rules but the frustration that
Hannity is experiencing because this is
becoming a clown show is well placed
Sean I understand the frustration I
promise you but I'm frustrated you
didn't answer my question and we are
hearing we are hearing from frustrating
who are still voting with Kevin McCarthy
do not answering my question of what
we're doing and they're cheering us on
so there are more for us than are
against us and they are waiting for
Kevin to keep
um
certainly frustrated by I'm frustrated
by you not answering a direct question
you said to president Trump the best you
said earlier today that President Trump
needs to tell Kevin McCarthy you don't
have the votes can I finish candidate to
elect it can I finish the house you
don't have the votes and it's time to
withdraw he has 203 your side has 20.
why is it time for him to withdraw and
not you when he has so many more votes
well Sean he needs 218 and he does not
have 218. we've been trying out in
private as you said for months but Kevin
McCarthy didn't even want to listen to
us until his disappointing midterms we
all want a
yeah so Sean Hannity making a perfectly
fine point it is also completely okay
for a republican who doesn't want Kevin
McCarthy to be speaker not to vote for
him but they need to understand the
consequences that's for them to figure
out then Lauren bobert says maybe I
should nominate Donald Trump tomorrow
and at this point Hannity just says what
you're turning this into a game show at
this point your final choice for speaker
and if you can't get more than let's say
30 votes will you follow your own advice
uh that you were asking Donald Trump and
withdrawal
there are certainly names that are being
floated around and hey maybe I should
nominate president Donald J Trump
tomorrow but Sean I I did watch your
show last it's a game show like we're
going to paint on this Motion
Picture Jim Jordan one day Donald's the
other day Trump the next day this motion
to vacate because Hannity is actually
correct in assessing the cartoonish and
childish nature of some elements of this
and this kept going
well not Sean I will not withdraw our
apps were were not Petty of Kevin
McCarthy they were not self-serving we
simply were asking for commitments on
what the American people want to see
they want to see a vote on term limits a
vote on the Texas border plan to secure
the southern border congresswoman we
asked for a vote on a budget that
actually
imagine imagine
a Congress that stops you only have 30
people supporting you right and we are
going to get the right speakers if you
only have 30 to be clear you will not
withdraw it's gonna be a beautiful
number but you're telling Kevin McCarthy
and the and the 203 people that support
him to withdraw because they don't have
218. that's what you're saying
look it's obvious by tonight's most
motion to adjourn that Kevin McCarthy
and his supporters are already getting
voter fatigue and I asked you a simple
question congresswoman I I she's not
going to answer it and uh Sean Hannity
is right to point out that she's not
answering it Sean Hannity is no better I
I don't want Sean Hannity in charge of
the house any more than I want Lauren
bobert in charge of the house but the
important thing that is of interest to
us here is that this is really really
bad for them now it's also bad for the
country let's take it in two parts later
I'll tell you why this is so bad for the
country and why it's a national security
risk that's the the that's one component
in terms of the Republican party this
undermines their unity and cohesion in a
literal sense Democrats are completely
United saying we want Hakeem Jeffries
we're all behind Akeem Jeffries and you
guys are running a clown show on the
Republican side the Republicans are
divided they look disorganized they're
it's Byron Donald's and then it's Jim
Jordan and then maybe bobert wants Trump
or whatever so this will damage their
reputation it will make it less likely
they achieve their goals if and when
they finally select a speaker which I
think is great
their goals are horrible I don't want
them to achieve their goals it distracts
from issues presumably they would want
to be working on it diverts time and
energy away from things they want to be
doing which is great I don't want them
doing the things they want to do it can
lead to a really prolonged period of
uncertainty and instability and that is
where it starts to become a national
concern and we'll talk about that a
little bit later and then as far as the
atmosphere within their party it's
getting extraordinarily toxic and again
I'm saying why it's bad for them I I
want it to be bad for them
but the atmosphere there relationships
trust between members oh it's we're
going to support Jordan and Donald and
this that the other thing and hopefully
it will lead to a prolonged power
struggle once this is done and I'm
guessing we've got another day or two of
this I don't know but I could be wrong I
thought we'd have a speaker on Tuesday
this could lead to a continued power
struggle over the next two years which
is great and then lastly
if they finally get a speaker under
these types of circumstances it will be
a speaker whose credibility and
Authority are not going to be solid it
is a very different thing to say we all
want Hakeem Jeffries Hakeem Jeffries is
the speaker the authority and
credibility of Jeffries is untainted
versus we had six eight twelve votes
shifting around support for alternatives
to McCarthy we eventually acquiesce if
that's what happens that hurts The
credibility and authority of the speaker
which again is bad for them so I hope
all of these things happen Hannity seems
to recognize that this is the way the
ball is increasingly rolling I'm sure
many of you will have questions about
this issue and others during our
upcoming viewer Town Hall it is
Wednesday January 11th at 6 PM Eastern
on our Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord it will be streaming live
everyone is invited to participate
members on our website will get Priority
Access to me on the Wednesday Town Hall
you can of course sign up at
joinpakman.com
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
lest anyone be confused the David
packman show is still supported by our
audience in 2023 I would love for you to
sign up at joinpakman.com not only will
you be directly supporting a program
that hopefully you find valuable you
also support all of the other things
we're doing including the free white
paper we've made available at
davidpackman.com guide the town halls
the content on new and growing platforms
and on and on and on you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code 24 starts now to get
yourself a discount earlier in the show
I told you all of the ways in which this
protracted Fiasco in the House of
Representatives wherein Republicans have
been unable to elect a speaker is bad
for Republicans now that's good that
makes me happy I think the Republican
party is terrible for the country I
think their goals and Ambitions are
destructive I want them to have a
quagmire and to be unable to push
forward their disgusting agenda
however
I don't want
the country to fail and as a general
principle not having a house speaker is
bad for the country and it's a national
security risk and it is a source of
instability on thebullwork.com
Joe perdicone or perticoni wrote an
article touching on some of these issues
called house is paralyzed without a
speaker creating National Security risks
and a shadow shutdown imagine if this
impasse were occurring in a presidential
inaugural year and Joe very precisely
and and astutely points out all of the
different ways in which this current
status quo is very bad including that no
one has actually been sworn into the
House of Representatives yet even though
George Santos said he was sworn in he
wasn't and we'll get to that a little
bit later and I think it's important
just to be clear about the risks that
this presents
it is I would argue even simpler than
Joe perdicone lays out it's not that
he's wrong but it's even simpler
this situation in the house where no one
has been sworn in and there is no
speaker
it can lead to a functional breakdown of
the House of Representatives the speaker
actually plays a critical role in
managing and organizing the legislative
process and with no speaker how does the
house conduct business and pass
legislation is it possible to do it is
but it's significantly more of a mess
within government no speaker and no
one's sworn in causes uncertainty it
causes instability the speaker is one of
the most powerful and influential
figures or positions in Congress and the
American confidence in government is
certain to decline the uh our perception
of the ability of the house to govern is
quite low accurately because this is
what they're doing and then you say okay
fine that's that's abstract but in
Practical terms what could that mean
well it can lead to gridlock or inaction
on important issues when you think about
um debt ceiling votes or if there's a a
natural disaster of some kind a crisis
an emergency uh the need for funding in
a specific Place way or form without a
speaker and without a sworn in-house it
is significantly more difficult for the
house to actually manage those things to
respond to unforeseen events and at the
end of the day to protect the country's
interests now do I think that
Republicans don't care about that no I
think at the individual level a lot of
these Republicans would honestly say no
I do care about that I understand that
I'm concerned does that mean they should
compromise on their principles to the
extent that this situation is is uh
caused by or catalyzed by their
principles no I'm not saying that but we
have to be factual we have to be honest
we have to be realistic the longer this
goes on
the more instability is accurately
perceived by the American people and
obviously the longer it goes on the the
higher the chances are that something
could happen domestically
internationally
and in other ways that would require in
normal circumstances the involvement of
the House of Representatives and they
will then be chaotically scrambling to
try to get involved help or do something
about it so
the primary interest from the we have uh
we have conflicting interests here each
faction of the Republican party wants to
reign supreme in terms of ultimately
deciding who is going to become speaker
of the house I get that that's politics
they don't want to be seen as the losers
they don't want to be seen as the ones
who were impotent in trying to impose
their preference of speaker that's one
area the impact on the Republican Party
we've already talked about on the other
hand I hope that I'm accurate in
assessing that the interest of the
American people
is to not have to think about the House
of Representatives and what I mean by
that is yes there are some people who
are more politically engaged than others
who pay attention to when are the
midterms where is control of the Senate
where is control of the house and are
more involved in that including people
like those who listen to this program
who watch our Clips the vast majority of
the country even many of those who vote
in the midterms don't spend their days
and nights thinking about this stuff and
so if it's sort of like referees in a in
a sporting event if you're noticing the
referees if you're thinking about the
referees if the referees are
significantly present in the game
arguably
it is because they are doing something
wrong or too involved or whatever the
case may be you've heard these Sports
analogies before and likewise I would
argue if the American people are
thinking about the chaos in the House of
Representatives to the extent that it
has been front and center for the last
two three days
um it is it is a bad thing it is the
type of thing where we shouldn't really
have to be thinking about it the house
is there there's a natural disaster
they're going to act they're going to
they're going to help they're going to
fund uh and that's where the National
Security risk comes here we now have a
balancing a coming together of how long
are they willing to continue this and
how tolerant will the American people be
before approval rating not only for the
house as a body where the approval
rating is always low but approval for
their individual members of Congress is
going to plummet I don't know the answer
to that but I'm guessing we're going to
start finding out about that very very
soon Lauren bobert appeared on Stephanie
rules program on MSNBC last night and it
was really humiliating absolutely
unhinged and humiliating for Lauren
bobert Lauren bobert of course has been
leading this anti-kevin McCarty leading
she's been involved in this anti-kevin
McCarthy
movement to the extent that it's a
movement in the Republican party they
have
um suggested everything from she might
nominate Donald Trump to who the hell
knows what else she appeared last night
with Stephanie Rule and you can tell
that she doesn't have any idea what's
going on she's stumbling around in the
dark she knows she's supposed to oppose
Kevin McCarthy uh and and her little
constituency is opposing Kevin McCarthy
but there's really no there there in
terms of the substance and Stephanie
rule makes this very very much apparent
no what these names are but I'm sure
that you're going to see a lot of names
beginning to emerge because we're
showing that we are willing to work to
unify the Republican party and get the
by the way imagine that the idea I'm
fine with them doing this it's
self-destructive but the idea that
bobert's actions are unifying is
laughable right okay sure and maybe it's
going to be me and Kim Kardashian and
anyone else who can be out there would
you like me to nominate you tomorrow how
long are you willing to wait I mean the
American people voted you in you waited
we could be here until the cherry
blossom you've got the power and every
day that passes that you're not doing
your jobs voters are saying hold on a
second I voted you in to get something
done right I don't know what these and
they're getting absolutely nothing done
as I've pointed out to you before and
the National Security risks that come
with it and the self-destructive risks
that come with it as well here's another
portion of this interview and again
bobert just doesn't know what she's
talking about she of course barely won
her race she has no business being in
elected office and you can tell she's
clueless actually I look at it in a very
different way I see it as congress not
spending money that they don't have
because every day that I've been in
Congress we've done exactly that so the
taxpayers are actually winning here
because Congress hasn't organized look
my conservative colleagues yeah I want
to by the way
this is uh you know when Marjorie Taylor
green was kicked off of her committees
one of the things I told you is we see
this as an embarrassment you've been
stripped of your duties you're being
sort of like sent home whatever
if you believe that Congress really
shouldn't do stuff if you are actually
one of these supposed small government
conservatives where you you kind of want
Congress to do and government to do as
little as possible you actually see some
of these things as wins and what bobert
is arguing I don't know if Republicans
are really think voters are thinking
about it this way but she's saying
listen uh we we run at a deficit and so
the longer Congress does nothing the
better it actually is financially now of
course the absurdity is taxpayer dollars
are still paying for what's going on in
the house chamber it's just they're
voting for speaker over and over again
it's still the same waste of money she
claims doing stuff is but she's trying
to tie in that small government ideology
in a way that's just laughable
on what the American people want to see
sure and with every passing day it's not
that Congress isn't spending money
anything that was put in place okay so
Stephanie rule making the argument I'm
making during Nancy Pelosi's term none
of that is going to stop and until you
put a speaker in place nothing that you
want to do is getting done right
well unfortunately the Senate took away
our Authority um to even work with a
budget of the next nine months Nancy
Pelosi is ruling with a dead hand anyway
they just
Stephanie rule is completely correct I
mean just a hundred percent completely
correct and then another funny moment
here where Stephanie rule points out to
Lauren bobert you barely won that secure
our Southern boy and then balance a
budget and
the American voter does want Congress to
work together right look at your last
election you represent a red District
that Donald Trump handily won and you
won narrowly and the takeaway for the
entire midterms is that the country said
we are done with Hyper partisanship we
want Congress to get to work and to work
together we saw today Mitch McConnell
President Biden Mike dewine them working
together talking infrastructure in
Kentucky and what you're doing today is
blocking your own party is that what
your voters asked you to do
so what I hear back at home all the time
for my constituents is they're Furious
about what the Democrats have been doing
all of this time they're Furious about
the Border crisis the energy crisis the
historic inflation and so much more and
we will handle these issues and conduct
serious oversight real soon when we get
the speaker's position right it's been
two days it's it's not the end of the
world we are going to come together we
tried to do this privately unfortunately
Kevin McCarthy wanted to take this
battle to the floor and that's where
we're at right now yeah so Stephanie
rule accurately and precisely exposing
that they don't even really know what
the end game is and as Lauren bobert
says it hasn't been that long we're
eventually going to come together at
this point enough damage has been done
that I mean listen eventually there's
going to be a speaker of the house if it
is indeed a republican speaker of the
house which most likely will be although
there's a scenario in which Hakeem
Jeffries becomes the speaker and just
nothing gets done because Republicans
would still be in the majority it will
be a weakened speaker it will be a
speaker lacking credibility and it will
be a Republican party lacking
credibility as well Hannity's been right
by saying they're turning this into a
clown show and they're turning this into
a game show and bobert becoming almost
like the spokesperson for this movement
she's already a clown show going in
making it even more so and uh I have to
tell you
it's horrible for the country I can't
control the fact that Republicans are
doing this and I would rather that they
didn't but to the extent that they are
that they are doing it and are damaging
themselves I welcome it we'll have all
of the clips I played here on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show and of course all of
these clips will be on our YouTube
channel make sure that you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show let's
make it to two million YouTube
subscribers this calendar year would be
a major accomplishment don't allow the
bystander effect to make you assume
someone else will subscribe be the
person who does it
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Dr
Gloria Mark who's the Chancellor's
professor at the University of
California Irvine she's studied
attention and stress in the digital age
for over two decades and is also author
of The forthcoming book out on Tuesday
January 10th attention span a
groundbreaking way to restore balance
happiness and productivity you can find
out more about it at gloriamark.com
really great having you on I I
appreciate the opportunity to talk about
this thank you for wrapping me so it's
almost become cliche Now to repeat some
of the things that have been written
many times there's no really such thing
as multitasking what you're doing is
quickly switching between tasks it's
also you know if you want to find uh
opinions that
um social media and smartphones are
killing our attention span you can find
it but now there's the next layer which
is hey you know maybe that's not
actually true when people do these
digital detoxes they don't really seem
to have the benefits some claim you can
basically find someone making every
claim at this point in time so maybe to
start we can just zoom out a little bit
and say
over the time that you have been
studying these issues are there
definitive trends that we can
um start with about the impact of modern
media smart phone social media on
attention on stress on anxiety
yes there are so um I've been studying
this empirically for almost two decades
now let me very quickly explain how I
study attention yeah so uh you know we
started out using stop watches and
shadowing people and every time someone
switched their attention or switched
screens we would uh note that we then
later switched to computer locking
techniques which are very precise very
objective and unobtrusive so we can get
precise measures of how long exactly
people's attention is on any screen
whether it's their computer or
smartphone and we find that over the
years people's attention on any screen
has diminished their length of attention
uh and in the last uh five years or so
we find that it's gone down to about 47
seconds on average if we look at the
midpoint it's called the median that we
find that half of all of our
observations of the length of attention
is actually less than 40 seconds 40
seconds is the median that means that
people switch their attention very fast
they don't spend a lot of time on any
particular screen and we know from when
we first started measuring this that the
length of attention spans have gone down
now it sounds like that's a bad thing
but maybe that's an assumption that we
should actually try to prove in some way
right I mean one one could say okay that
that's true that's what's going on but
it's just a result of the way that the
world is it doesn't objectively mean
that there's a cost or a negative is
there a cost or a negative to that
reality yeah unfortunately there is a
cost because we find a strong
relationship between the frequency of
Shifting attention and stress so stress
goes up as attention is is shifted now
going back to years of laboratory
research in Psychology we know that when
people switch their attention when they
multitask among you know switching among
different tasks blood pressure goes up
there's a a physiological marker in the
body that also indicates that people are
under stress we also know that when
people are are probed with validated
questionnaires about their subjective
stress their perceived stress also goes
up at times when people are are shifting
their attention multitasking fast so
there is a cost yes when we talk about
the Stress and Anxiety component it
seems important to distinguish for to
take one example to take social media on
the one hand we have these aspects of
the rapidity with which you can switch
between things when you're scrolling
social media the distractive element of
picking it up and looking at it when
maybe you should be spending an hour
consecutively working so that's one side
we then have the stuff that people like
Jonathan height and others look at more
which is the effect of the content and
does seeing people's best moments when
you're just sitting at home in your
pajamas and comparing or right there's
the content aspect when it comes to kids
in school the way that some bullying has
moved into the social media space these
are two different things how can we
distinguish the impact of one from the
impact of the other
yeah so you you would have to do some
controlled studies so you'd have to
basically give people uh
uh social media that has positive
content and then give them social media
that might have negative content and
then you look at the differences so
you're you're controlling that uh and
then there's other things you can
control too such as the length of posts
and see what impact that has but there's
absolutely uh no question that social
media is uh it's two-sided right there's
there's benefits we we can't deny that
there are benefits for young people they
can have they can be socially connected
to other people especially during the
pandemic right it was really a great
benefit for a number of people not not
just young people uh but of course there
is a negative side as well as you
mentioned cyber bullying there's missing
information so there's absolutely no
question that there's you know it's a
double-edged sword so if we assume that
the majority of my audience kind of
understands the the guideposts here of
the concern and of the reality of what's
going on
um let's talk a little bit about sort of
like how One what safeguards or
behaviors one can kind of cultivate for
for themselves
um Neil Postman in his book technopoly
you know like 30 years ago wrote about
uh whenever there's a new technology
there's good and there's bad the idea of
saying let's only allow the good through
regulation it rarely works and we really
just need to to kind of think through
the best way to welcome these
Technologies in total all right and and
sort of limit limit the damage that they
can do what should people be doing is it
you know practically is it you put your
phone in a different room you set a
timer and use these techniques where you
work 25 minutes I think it's the
Pomodoro Technique 25 minutes and then a
five minute break and then you switch to
something else and is that is it
practical to think people can really do
that regularly
yeah so first of all consider there are
individual differences so personality
absolutely plays a role in people's
ability to self-regulate some people are
more lucky they have good uh good
abilities for self-regulation other
people are not born some lucky but if
you're not born lucky there are things
you can do to change people can develop
agency over their behaviors and if we
draw from the work of a very famous
social psychologist Albert bandura he's
found that people in a number of areas
can develop self-efficacy so with
stopping smoking substance abuse and so
I believe that it's very possible for
people to have control over their
attention
uh how can they gain an agency there's
different ways first of all uh you can
learn to be more intentional in your
behavior so we do a lot of automatic uh
behaviors for example we check our our
smartphones you know just automatically
without thinking we check email we go to
social media
what you can do is you can learn it to
probe yourself to bring your your
unconscious actions uh to become more
conscious uh I'm a professional Observer
of people when I study them and I've
learned to become a professional
Observer of Myself by probing myself
probing the reasons why I'm doing things
so whenever I have an urge to go to
social media I recognize that urge I ask
myself will I get value out of being
there why do I have this need to go
there am I bored am I doing a hard task
right and anyone can develop this skill
to become an observer of themselves and
once you recognize reasons for why
you're doing things you can change right
and if you go to social media to take a
break then again you can probe yourself
and say am I still getting value or am I
just getting marginal returns and if
you're just getting marginal returns
it's time to get back to work uh let me
mention another uh technique that people
can do is to practice what's called
forethought forethought means imagining
your future self and it could be in the
very near future like at the end of the
day if you go on social social media now
how is that going to impact your life at
10 pm or midnight are you still going to
be working on that deadline or are you
going to be relaxing have a glass of
wine watching your favorite show think
ahead right another uh technique that
people can do is to maintain their
higher level goals in their mind goals
are a great Shield against distractions
if because because attention is directed
to what our goals are and if your goal
is that you're going to work on this
deadline and finish it right then your
attention will be directed to it
one of the people I've interviewed
before is Cal Newport who writes a lot
about carving time out for what he calls
deep work and of course at the very you
know minimum that means you're not
checking your smartphone during this
time but ideally also there you're
you're limiting other distractions in
other ways and you know we've talked
with him about that one of the things
that seems to apply in the diet world
that may also apply here is whatever
you're doing needs to be sustainable it
seems like and that's one of the better
arguments I've read against the total
sort of like uh social media
um sabbatical of sorts which is that it
creates what's really an artificial
situation that that nobody says is going
to be the long-term situation and that
therefore it might be sort of a limited
value whereas maybe there's more value
to saying hey you know I know I have a
tendency to do my best deep work in the
morning so from 9 to 11 I'm not even
gonna have my phone in the room and and
so now I'm at least getting to 11
without any distractions and then from
then on I will do X Y or Z that that
type of thing can you talk a little bit
about is it better to jump right into
modes that are sustainable long term or
do these short-term experiments have
their place
no I I don't think that realistically uh
we can think about doing digital detoxes
for a very long time you know if if any
individual does a digital detox
essentially it penalizes themselves
because they're cutting themselves off
from important work Communications from
family from loved ones and you're right
absolutely it's not sustainable we we
live in a digital world the ship has
sailed we can't back away from it we
can't pull out so what we need to do
instead is to think of solutions that uh
that can enable us to live in this world
and to maintain well-being now it turns
out that people
um you know you can't maintain sustained
Focus for a lengthy period just in the
same way that you can't lift weights for
an extended period of time we we use up
our mental resources now people have
Peaks of time during the day when their
mental resources are at their utmost
and for most people it's mid to late
morning and it's mid-afternoon if you
can become aware of when your personal
peaks of attention are
and you can start with with these times
that I mentioned uh then you can gear
your work around those times when your
attention is is at its best yeah that's
been super useful for me we're very you
know I used to have a list of things
that I sort of plan to accomplish after
taping my show each day and I learned
that I would get only to a fraction of
that list just because of sort of like
mood and who knows other things that
that maybe I can't necessarily identify
but I found that the more I plan to do
before filming each day
dramatically more efficient dramatically
more productive and so now I kind of
tail I know that if I get to my desk 15
minutes earlier I'm going to do way more
than if I think of doing that at 3 pm
now I have the benefit of a job where
I'm completely in control of my schedule
the reality is a lot of people are
squeezing these things in around shift
work for example and that becomes very
difficult
that's right absolutely so so that's
right you know every person is different
everyone has their own personal Rhythm
uh and you need to gear your work around
what your own personal rhythm is for for
your attentional resources and you know
for me I I can't start work immediately
when I get up I I need time to ramp up
so I I do easy things when I start you
know I I will take care of email I'll
read the news and then you know I'm a
little bit geared up and then I can
start diving into doing hard work and
then I'm at my Peak now you know people
can discover their Peak by you know
finding out what your chronotype is some
people are early types some people are
late types it can serve as a guide at
least to get you started but become
aware of when you start feeling
exhausted and the best thing you can do
is pull back take a break get
replenished and then you can go back in
with with a full tank of resources we
have been speaking with Dr Gloria Mark
uh the book which is out on Tuesday
January 10th is attention span a
groundbreaking way to restore balance
happiness and productivity productivity
you can find out more at
www.gloriamark.com really appreciate
your time and your insights today
thank you so much for having me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's look at a few other
things that happened yesterday a George
Santos seemed to forget his own name on
the floor of the house multiple times
his name was called a four vote on
speaker of the house on the fifth ballot
he seems not to recognize uh his own
name which is just funny because of
course his his full name is George
Anthony devalder Santos and it raises a
question of whether does he even really
go by George Santos normally maybe he
goes by Anthony devalder or George
dewalder or Anthony Santos I don't know
but here he is they call him multiple
times doesn't seem to recognize they're
calling him for a vote the guy to his
right seems to tell him like Hey that's
your name sir
Santos
Santos
sarbanes okay and they move on to
sarbanes and then he held up his hand
and yells out that he's voting for
McCarthy
Jeffries you even you even see Matt
Gates come by just kind of like what is
it that is even going on here
um so just kind of weird everything
about Santos is strange for all we know
he's used to being called some other
name I don't know and um it seems that
he is continuing to struggle to sort of
uh build community in the House of
Representatives and I don't really know
the end game for Santos I The First 48
hours are not sustainable running away
with a huge backpack running away from
reporters who want to ask him questions
sitting by himself in the floor of the
house picking his nose not recognizing
his own name and it's it's all just
truly bizarre but I also have kind of
like a morbid curiosity where like how
how awkward can this possibly get and
you all know I love awkward so we're
going ahead and gonna go ahead and
follow that and by the way the lies from
George Santos haven't stopped since he
arrived in Washington DC let's talk
about that next George Santos lied about
being sworn in on Tuesday I don't know
how else to explain this to you George
Santos was not sworn in on Tuesday
nobody was but he put out a press
release saying he was sworn in
it's very binary it's not a matter of
opinion it's not a technicality he was
not sworn in on Tuesday but he posted a
press release saying that he indeed was
uh the office of
um George Santos publishing on Tuesday
press release swearing in as member of
the 118th Congress U.S representative
George Santos was sworn in as a member
of the United States House of
Representatives by the Speaker of the
House on January 3rd 2023. hilariously
not only is that not true there was no
speaker they were they're voting on a
speaker the whole problem is there's no
speaker and he's like oh yeah the
speaker I was sworn in by the speaker on
Tuesday no it didn't happen
um if you now go and look at Santos's
website this press release has been
deleted it now says access denied you
are not authorized to access this page
um because it's not true they had to
remove it swearing-in of course happens
after the speaker has been elected after
the speaker has been elected so my
question to you about this is the
following De Santos know that he wasn't
sworn in and this was published as a lie
because he must have staff you would
think if he goes to his staff and says
hey um please publish that I was sworn
in
you'd think someone would say oh you
weren't sworn in you're you haven't been
sworn in that happens after the speaker
is selected so I don't really understand
how this ends up being the thing that
happens it's very very strange uh tell
me what you think did was it a lie was
he confused whatever
Steve Almond has been a guest on my
program multiple times and I don't like
calling Steve a sports writer because he
writes about so many things but Steve
does sometimes write about sports Laura
Ingram on Fox News thought it would be a
good idea to bring Steve Almond on last
night to talk about what's going on with
Demar Hamlin who suffered a cardiac
arrest during the game on Monday night
we've talked about it already to some
degree
but this was a very very bad idea for
Laura Ingram
um he brings up
that Fox News has thrown money to settle
sexual assault claims in sort of making
an analogy to how the NFL will settle
brain injury stuff without actually
changing the underlying circumstances of
football that allow the brain injuries
to become common
everything about this interview is
absolutely fantastic and eventually
Laura Ingram just cuts it off when he
tries to bring up Laura Ingram's past
misdeeds when she taunted Parkland
shooting survivors a leading advertisers
to flee her show this is really good
let's go to the first clip putting
monitors and helmets to try to make sure
that people aren't suffering too many
concussive or sub-concussive events
these are things the NFL could do
tomorrow but they're not going to do it
until there's an economic incentive the
reason they settled that lawsuit is
because they had a PR problem it's like
at Fox News when you have you know hosts
who are allegedly sexually harassing
people Fox News throws money at that
tonight that PR problem go away that's
what happens
in people well nobody nobody has done
more I mean you know that right you know
that yeah that's a cute little mo but I
love it I know every time guests call
out fox on Fox these hosts have some
line like oh that's cute that's a cute
move now he's showing up and he's
pointing out that that which you are
criticizing someone else for your
employer also does it's not about being
cute it's that they don't know how to
handle it when guests actually Point
these things out let's go to another
clip here they have enormous amount of
fans what happened
I mean they changed the whole corporate
approach to race and equity and and all
the things that happened two and a half
years ago so you say the players don't
have all that much influence I would say
the players have an enormous amount of
influence maybe not as much as they want
but there's there's huge economic upside
for everyone here correct
well I know you're focused on the
players I'm focused on the fans
and what I essentially believe is not
that any government ban is going to make
football safer and certainly not some
Mythic woke mob that you mentioned to
try to scare your viewers I think it's
going to happen
football's not about politics it's not
about politics your entire economic
model your entire economic models
I mean Steve you're really why wait you
really want to change your behavior yeah
you want football to be bad
oh come on you you what you you want
football essentially changed into I
don't know what like I don't know we
have a sensor in the helmet I guess okay
propose one you know is that is that
technology troubling to you no not in
this if you're concerned about the
players why wouldn't you want to play in
a way that is safer you're not concerned
about the play the thing about people
like Laura Ingram is Steve Almond
accurately points out
it's it is about scaring viewers it's
all about scaring viewers and when it
comes to football the way they see the
really scary thing about football and I
now have friends who have kids who are
sort of starting to get curious about
football and they're like oh my goodness
the last thing I want is my kid to play
football so they're trying to find a
balance between straight up saying you
were not allowed to play because then
that can cause this kind of reaction
where the kid goes well I really want to
play if I'm not allowed to play just
kind of finding the right way to
dissuade softly dissuade uh their kids
from wanting to play football the thing
about football is it is fundamentally
dangerous the brain injury stuff is
completely off the charts it's shocking
to me that football even still sort of
exists at the college level and I think
it's possible that if and when the
lawsuits start at the college level uh
it will really really damage the the
prospects of football I find it you know
mildly entertaining there's other sports
I like better but it just seems crazy
that it's still a thing Laura Ingram
and her model in the model of foxes
we've got to scare the audience we have
to scare the audience and and ideally
about what the left or or someone uh
external to our movement is doing
so with football it's they want to have
a nanny state where they ban a sport
or they want to over regulate football
by saying oh you've got to do this
you've got to do that you've got to
force players out concussion Protocols
are too strict or sensors in the helmet
it's all crazy or what it all has to be
fear fear fear they're going to take it
away and with football there's also the
patriotism angle which they love which
is there's something patriotic and manly
it's both patriotic and manly and so any
skepticism about football and and
football's viability is not only [ __ ]
it's also anti-American this is the
whole sort of narrative but when it like
comes right down to it Laura Ingram kind
of has no choice but to say no I mean I
guess I'd be fine with a sensor with a
sensor in the helmet that indicates you
know what were the what were the
g-forces was there a possible concussion
or whatever the case may be because
these are these are perfectly logical
things as half measures to really
dealing with football big picture now
this is not the hill I'm going to die on
I'm not going around looking to end
football it's shocking to me that
anybody lets their kids play football at
this point and I know let them you know
how what that that's a whole difficult
premise premise as well but this is how
these folks operate make everybody
afraid Steve Allman's completely right
when it comes down to it you go well
it's not so much that I'm opposed to
thing number one or two or three but we
should be very afraid of what they are
trying to do here's the last segment
during which Steve Allman points out
she had a problem with advertisers
fleeing for things she said and then she
just ends the interview so thrilling the
reason that people change their behavior
is because there's an economic incentive
a couple years ago when you talked like
a Survivor apartment mass shooting
um
nice try buddy I appreciate it it's cut
it is cut cut
um yeah so other guests have done this
stuff before and the reaction from the
hot Fox hosts is is very similar it's
cut it laugh it off and say it's an
ambush or it's cute or it's funny or
whatever the case may be standard Mo
they all seem to know how to do it but
very nicely done by Steve Almond and I
mean listen this is Steve Allman's
bailiwick right that to invite him and
think he's not going to do this is
really the thing that shows you don't
really know who who he is really nice
job we should have him back on the show
soon we have a voicemail number and that
number is
2192 David P
uh the anti-vaxxers have immediately
swarmed over what happened on the field
on Monday where a football player Damar
Hamlin suffered a cardiac arrest and uh
here is uh here's a call about exactly
that
hey David
this is Joshua from the Philadelphia
suburbs yes calling about something that
I've seen
um circulating around the internet over
the past few days since the Demar Hamlin
medical scare earlier this week the
safety from the Buffalo Bills who had a
cardiac arrest
um in certain areas of conspiracy
frightening
social media there is this a true
attribution that it's because of a
coveted vaccine
rather than the fact that a six foot
four 220 pound opponent struck him in
the chest running full force right
um I have a medical doctor uh I can tell
you that
um one of those causes is far more
likely and that I think it has more to
do with the one
um that's gonna knock you on your back
rather than eating a Band-Aid on your
adulthood however I don't think you need
10 years of postgraduate training to
know that I think so yeah and and again
we do not even know the vaccination
status of Demar Hamlin or at least we
didn't as of yesterday when I I last
read about this and there are so many
leaps in logic that are being made here
that it is really it's truly a scary
thing that these folks for whom again
they've got a hammer which is vaccines
are bad that's their Hammer so
everything is a nail someone gets
covered oh it's because of the vaccine
someone has a heart attack it's because
of the vaccine
someone dies it's because of the vaccine
everything is the vaccine because all
they've got is a hammer and it's a
really sad situation we've got and a
destructive one I should add great bonus
show for you today we'll talk about
um something interesting going on with
Millennials in politics
Southwest Airlines involved in a
controversy a Maga hat wearing teacher
has been
um in a sense Vindicated legally all of
it is on the bonus show today oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
yeah everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves as bad sign up at
joinpakman.com and we will see you then